bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mercredi 4
mai merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale nous vous l'expliquons
entourés de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite pour commencer
les titres de cette édition
le compteur linky commence son
déploiement dans les yvelines hier à
meaux le premier compteur intelligent de
erdf a été installé le début d'un vaste
chantier en france et 35 millions de
compteurs qui seront remplacés si d'ici
je ne rougis pas de l'évangile c'est le
titre du livre publié par le diocèse de
versailles son objectif favoriser le
dialogue interreligieux entre chrétiens
et musulmans
pour nous en parler ce soir notre invité
le père xavier chavanne curé des mureaux
il ya participé à l'écriture de l'
ouvrage et après les attentats de 2015
en france l'armée de terre recrute mais
surtout séduit de plus en plus de jeunes
ils sont nombreux à vouloir s'engager
aujourd'hui
reportage en immersion au fort de
vincennes pendant les sélections et test
de recrutement nous avons suivi antoine
un jeune il viennois de 20 ans et je
vous le disais en titre le compteur
linky arrive dans les yvelines c'est
dans la commune de molières que le
premier compteur intelligent de erdf a
été installé le début d'un chantier
pharaonique puisqu'en france 35 millions
de compteurs seront remplacés jusqu'en
2021 pour un coût de 5 milliards d'euros
un compteur qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la loi européenne sur la transition
énergétique et qui offre de nombreux
nouveaux services aux clients plus de
précision avec william l c'est le
premier compteur linky installés dans le
département des yvelines
le 3 mai un maul erdf a lancé le
déploiement de son nouveau compteur
intelligent
l'objectif équipé 90 % du territoire
français en remplaçant 35 millions de
compteurs sur les cinq prochaines années
linky est un compteur électrique de
nouvelle génération qui va apporter
grand nombre de services nouveaux à nos
concitoyens et leur permettent de faire
des économies sur leurs factures et des
économies d'énergie sur le territoire
des yvelines on remplacera 650000 un peu
plus de 650000 compteur à l'horizon
également en 2021 pour la première année
le déploiement commencera autour de
trois zones
les mureaux saint quentin en yvelines et
vélizy pour s'étendre progressivement
sur le reste du département
la pose du compteur ne nécessite que 30
minutes et sera effectué par des
entreprises locales partenaires de erdf
linky pendant la période de pause qui
s'échelonne jusqu'en 2021 va créer dix
mille emplois en france 5000 pour la
construction des compteurs de l'ensemble
des compteurs sont construits sont
montés en france sont assemblés en
france
et puis 5000 emplois qui vont être
dédiés à la pause pour erdf line qui
permet de piloter son réseau plus
efficacement à distance pour le client
c'est l'opportunité de mieux gérer sa
consommation d'énergie en la suivant
directement sur internet
tout ce qui permet de réduire un peu sa
consommation est positif puis on a
l'habitude maintenant des éléments
communiquant à table est le téléphone
donc ça fait partie du pack à standard
maintenant de l'habitat non vraiment le
but pour moi c'est de pouvoir aller sur
internet de savoir quasiment un instant
t combien je consomme et par-delà
anticipé un peu ma consommation et de
voir la note effectivement effective à
payer aucun changement n'est à effectuer
sur l'installation électrique ou les
appareils ménagers pour éviter tout
démarchage frauduleux erdf insiste sur
le fait que l'installation du compteur
est notifié aux clients par courrier au
minimum un mois al avance et nous vous
en parlions hier dans notre journal avec
notre invité à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la huitième édition de la semaine
de la mémoire de l'esclavagé ville de
guyancourt maurepas montigny le
bretonneux et trappes accueille divers
animations jusqu'au 10 mai ce matin ces
deux écoles de billancourt qui était
reçu par les membres du collectif pour
la semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé
pour de la numération mélanie poké et
guillaume le squer étaient sur place
rien et c'est ce qu'on veut rappeler n'a
donc de conditions de temps disons de
voilages atroce une traversée du trio
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
moulait
l'histoire de l'esclavagé dans leur
programme scolaire ces élèves de cm2 de
l'école francis poulenc de lui en course
plomb ce matin dans l'histoire française
quand les pas de france de la france le
département du commerce
ce département d'outre-mer de lavage
donc la martinique la guadeloupe la
réunion découverte de termes propres à
l' esclavage des dates clés de cette
histoire mais aussi des ouvrages
accessibles à tous autour de cette
notion
ça m'a fait du mal pour eux parce qu'ils
avaient rien fait ils étaient des
esclaves nos manuels scolaires
maintenant aborde les esclavages de
façon explicite mais le programme
d'histoire est très large
et puis chaque année de plus en plus
large puisqu'on a toute l'histoire du
20e siècle puisqu'une somme 21e siècle
donc en fait on n'a pas toujours
l'occasion de pouvoir approfondir cette
cette histoire la semaine de la mémoire
de l'esclavagé sur saint quentin en
yvelines continue jusqu'au 10 mai date
de la journée nationale des mémoires de
la traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions
ce pourrait bien être à présent le
circuit film des kids mgm de la ville de
trappes a été dévoilée ce matin
l'événement mettra en valeur le
triathlon le triathlon pardon dans 34
villes de france l'événement qui dès
aura lieu à trappes le 1er juin il est
destiné en priorité aux enfants de 5 à
12 ans plusieurs ateliers seront mis en
place tout au long de la journée autour
du développement durable du droit des
enfants ou encore de la santé
les détails avec william l
c'est officiel les filets skids mgen
passeront par trappe le 1er juin
prochain
c'est la deuxième fois que ces journées
de la forme sont organisées dans cette
ville où environ 500 enfants de 5 à 12
ans pourront participer au triathlon
on va faire un triathlon sur des
distances adaptées à l'âge des enfants
un triathlon d'initiation on va faire 20
m de natation dans une piscine que nous
installerons le matin même on partira
sur le parking de la mairie sur des
boucles pour arriver à réaliser un
kilomètre de vélo puis après avoir posé
le vélo on part en course à pied la
troisième discipline du triathlon
jusqu'à passer la ligne d'arrivée sur le
parking bas à côté de la mairie
en plus d'un village éphémère pour
s'amuser découvrir les droits de
l'enfant de nombreux ateliers pour
inculquer des valeurs citoyennes seront
organisées même si l'objectif principal
du film days qu'ils restent de
démocratiser la discipline du triathlon
auprès des plus jeunes
la plus belle phrase que j'ai entendu à
propos des fidèles mgen c'est apprendre
aux enfants à vivre demain
apprendre aux enfants à vivre ensemble à
faire du sport ensemble à trier leurs
déchets à préserver leur environnement à
accepter les différences avec les autres
tous ces ateliers qui vont permettre
pendant un peu près une heure et demie
de délivrer un message aux deux enfants
des messages de citoyenneté et de
bien-être
toujours à partir du sport les fidèles
ce qu'ils restent une initiation
ici pas de compétition de classement
l'important est de participer
il pourrait qu'on pense à chaque étape
un tirage au sort aura lieu pour emmener
les gagnants à la finale nationale le 12
juillet prochain à castellane sport
toujours le rugby club de versailles
lancée cet après-midi le versailles
seven anton interlycées cissé de la
commune ont répondu présent et 60 élèves
se sont affrontés dans des matchs de
rugby à 7
l'objectif est d'attirer des futur
rugbyman a joué en club mais aussi de
dynamiser la pratique du rugby à cette
nouvelle épreuve olympique si vous ne
savez pas on écoute tout de suite
nicolas loubards directeur technique du
club de versailles il est est au micro
de camille lambert on évolue dans un
moment festif et de rassemblement
conjuguer le jeu du rugby à 7 qui a un
jeu très ludique et aéré spectaculaire à
voir avec justement là
l'esprit festif de faux débats sportifs
et 2007
on va le refaire chaque année en fait
donc c'est la première année on va
renouveler chaque année ce tournoi
et voici de s'enrichir d'autres lycées
donc il ya d'autres lycées dans gaza
grand parc combat auquel on va demander
de participer
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien du jour nous recevons ce soir
en plateau le père xavier chavanne curé
des mureaux bonsoir à vous soit merci
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vous êtes si pour nous parler d'un
livre
il s'intitule je ne rougis pas de
l'évangile il a été publié aux éditions
mame par le diocèse de versailles
alors c'est un ouvrage d'accompagnement
pour favoriser le dialogue deux fois
entre chrétiens et musulmans c'est bien
ça oui exactement à partir de 11 et le
constat que souvent les chrétiens et
notamment les jeunes en âge de collèges
de lycées a été un peu déstabilisé par
l'affirmation de la foi des musulmans et
du coup souvent été un peu savaient pas
très bien comment répondre donc voilà on
sait on
on s'est dit qu'il était temps pour pour
pour nos jeunes de ne pas rougir de leur
foi de dire que sur toutes les questions
qui touchent dieu le paradis l'éthique
la pratique religieuse
ils ont des choses à dire et à témoigner
voilà alors c'est un projet qui date de
2011 c'est ça une idée qui est un petit
peu cheminée avant d'être rattachée de
finir en livre finalement voilà en 2011
il ya eu un synode diocésain où l'évêque
a souhaité que lier la parole soit
donnée aux jeunes aux 15-25 ans et qu'il
y ait des équipes de 15 25 ans qui
disent ce qu'ils voulaient
voir naître dans l'église diocésaine et
ce qui est revenu le plus souvent chez
les équipes de jeunes c'est les
questions interreligieuse et en
approfondissant un peu avec eux c'était
de fait cette question que qui revenait
très souvent c'est que les jeunes
musulmans savent
dire pourquoi ils sont musulmans et les
jeunes chrétiens peut-être parce qu'ils
sont issus d'une société qui a des
racines chrétiennes forte mais qui
m'aimait à arrive pas à dire les mots
qui vont expliquer ce que ça veut dire
pour eux d'être chrétien m en parallèle
ou en opposition les passions petit et
ce terme je les jeunes musulmans voient
pas les jeunes eux est juif ou peut-être
de trop lyon parce que les jeunes
chrétiens étaient vraiment confrontés à
cette question
c'est pas nouveau quand j'étais j'ai
commencé mon ministère de prêtre à
sartrouville en 81 18 je me souviens
d'un groupe de lycéens chrétiens qui
viennent me voir et qui me disent père
xavier on a eu une discussion dans la
cour avec des amis musulmans
ils nous ont dit comment vous croyez en
3 dieu qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous
croyez en trois dieux comment vous priez
et on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
beaucoup de mal à leur expliquer ce qui
était notre foi alors voilà on aimerait
créer un petit groupe qui nous permet de
réfléchir sur comment
qu'est ce que c'est que la prière
chrétienne et qu'est ce que c'est que la
trinité voilà on a démarré avec ça il
fallait participer donc à l'écriture se
trouvait jamais vous pas seul comme ça
c'est un petit peu passé il va un
dialogue avant avec des jeunes pour
justement faire cet ouvrage qui
s'organise donc en neuf chapitres
oui alors il ya eu pendant une année une
équipe qui a travaillé qui était composé
de
trois jeunes adultes et de deux prêtres
qui ont recueilli les expressions qui
revenait souvent qu'ils étaient des
interpellations de musulmans fait à des
jeunes chrétiens
comment vous pouvez dire que jésus est
fils de dieu dieu n'a pas de fils
puisqu'il est unique par exemple ou
comment pouvez vous dire que dieu a
laissé mourir son prophète jésus sur une
croix c'est indigne de dieu comment vous
pouvez qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui est
interdit dans votre religion nous le
port l'alcool tout ça c'est interdit et
vous c'est quoi les interdits dans votre
religion voilà donc c'était des
interpellations très réel fait que des
musulmans expriment aujourd'hui à des
jeunes chrétiens partir de là et puis
une fois que cette équipe avait repéré
lc dilma comme on en commet on prend
cela en compte
qu'est ce qu'on dit qu'est ce que la foi
chrétiens nous dit on pose un regard
aussi chrétien sur ce que les musulmans
dit sur cette question
et puis et puis à la fin on essaie de
trouver quelques motifs de joie d'être
d'être chrétien alors donc je le disais
alors le lycée mise en oeuvre chapitre i
par du contenu de la foi chrétienne et
jeu ce qu'on dise les musulmans sous la
forme de neuf interpellations qui est
dieu la personne de jésus la mort de
jésus bible et coran valeur et validité
des écritures
je ne crierai aumône interdit conversion
et apostasie enfer et paradis existe il
un lien entre jésus est mort mais on
voit aussi qu'il ya des des liens des
ressemblances forcément toutes les
religions je pense notamment aux jeunes
et au ramadan soit ce que je vais a
voulu mettre en avant
exactement par exemple jésus est on le
rappelle au début de chaque carême les
chrétiens réentendre les paroles de
jésus sur l'aumône sur la prière est
sûre le jeune donc l'aumône a plié le
jeune sont au coeur même de l'expérience
du carême que nous vivons est alors
souvent les musulmans ou une expression
qui revient souvent auprès des jeunes
chrétiens en disant nous le ramadan
c'est comme le carême pour le chrétien
sauf que nous on fait sérieusement et du
coup alors on entend sa caisse
veut dire de faire sérieusement le
carême c'est vrai quand on regarde par
exemple ce que dit jésus sur l'aumône le
jeûne et la prière
jésus ainsi sur le fait en dix ans fait
le discrètement de telle sorte que
personne ne remarque que tu es en train
de jeûner ou que tu es en train de prier
ou que tu entres voilà là il ya une
spécificité chrétienne de dire 'voilà
l'aumône le jeune et partage c'est la
prière sont des points communs que nous
avons en soient chrétiens ou musulmans
mais quand on est chrétien on nous
demande pendant le carême de le faire
très discrètement de façon à ce que ça
ne se voit pas que les autres ne le voit
pas seul dieu qui est dans le secret le
voit est leur vaudra alors ses tarifs
c'est un projet qui a été également plus
en réaction à l'expansion de la religion
musulmane dans les ive et sac et un
grand nombre de conversions ce livre est
ce que c'est un outil pour empêcher cela
parle pour empêcher les personnes de
chercher dieu et d'avancer de progresser
sur le sur le chemin de dieu mais pour
permettre aux jeunes qu'ils sont
chrétiens et qui se demandent pourquoi
ils le sont et pis qui puisse témoigner
autour d'eux de cette joie d'être
chrétiens de ne pas avoir honte je ne
rougis pas de l'évangile reste que
l'allemand béria est un problème pour
l'église catholique vraiment alors
l'apostasié et le fait de renoncer à sa
foi pour un chrétien comme d'ailleurs
dans la religion musulmane c'est une
blessure
on va voir 1 1
un péché voilà jésus dit voilà je ne
rougirait que de ceux qui ont rougi deux
mois voilà donc mais très souvent on
peut pas reprocher à des jeunes qui ne
sont plus dans une relation vivante avec
jésus d'être attirés vers l'islam qui
leur parlent de dieu killer qui les
invite à la prière qui les invite à
avancer sur un sur un chemin de foi ou
un chemin spirituel pour nous c'est pas
un problème dans ce sens là donc si si
c'est un progrès voilà en revanche ce
qu'on peut se dire c'est comme chrétien
au réveille toi un peu où toi qui dort
voilà réveille-toi devient sache
pourquoi tu es chrétien et n'ai pas
honte tu as à prier on entend partout
dans nos églises encore dans les
yvelines
trois fois par jour l'angélus sonné
combien de chrétiens
quand ils entendent l'angélus pense à
prier et cette prière toute simple qui
rappelle l'incarnation de dieu sur terre
dieu qui se fait l'un d'entre nous qui
pensent à ça quand il entend l'angélus à
voir avec les temps de se réveiller un
peu les cloches sont là pour nous
réveiller
mais maintenant passons aux actes voilà
voilà aujourd'hui en france quand on ne
peut pas nier la religion musulmane
attire de plus en plus et de plus en
plus de personnes peut-être plus que la
religion chrétienne comment vous
analyser ça moi j'y vois deux de raisons
mais je ne prétends pas être
être un spécialiste dans la domaine dans
le domaine moi je dis d'abord il ya je
pense une raison culturelle
c'est à dire que clairement nous sommes
dans une société et nous n'ayons pas
honte là non plus qui est des racines
judéo-chrétiennes profondément ancrées
donc il ya beaucoup de comportements
dans notre société qui fait que
globalement on se situe dans une
situation dans une société chrétienne et
du coup les les jeunes notamment les
jeunes ont un peu de mal à faire la
différence entre un incroyant chrétiens
et puis un citoyen français qui vit et
qui pratique les valeurs qu'il est qui
rallieront de prix sont élevés qui sont
nés dans l'évangile et du coup il ya ses
valeurs d'ouverture à l'autre de
tolérance d'amour du prochain de charité
voilà elles sont assez naturelle et donc
ils se disent pas et comme c'est quand
même ce qu'il ya de plus important
vivre cette charité voilà et du coup ben
oui on apprenait sur une réaction de
position par rapport à la société
française et du coup on cette société
française où malgré tout il ce qui a
grandi ces dernières années et continue
à grandir c'est l'oubli de dieu et le
fait que dieu ne soit plus présent à
l'esprit des personnes et notamment la
perte de la prière est bien fait que des
jeunes chrétiens ou des jeunes tout
court quand les musulmans eux parlent de
dieu et disent que l'oubli de dieu
on ne peut pas vivre en oubliant dieu et
sans penser à dieu de fait les jeunes
sont attirés vers ce qu'ils leur disent
alors que nous comme chrétien comme on
est dans cette société depuis des
générations l'église on pense peu à
interpeller en disant oh là là vous êtes
en train d'oublier dieu penser à dieu
voilà depuis que les cloches nous le
rappelle mais notre discours aujourd'hui
la depuis la publication de vous
rencontrer un certain succès ce que vous
y attendiez non c'est plutôt une
heureuse
surprise nous savons qu'il y avait des
bonnes raisons de faire ce livre
puisqu'il était demandé et nous sommes
heureusement surpris que se livrent
répondent à des demandes j'ai encore
reçu il ya il ya deux jours un sms de
d'une responsable du catéchisme une
maman antillaise à meulan et qui
s'occupe d'aider des du catéchisme sur
blanc et qui me disait qu'elle avait
trouvé le livre quel prix qu'elle avait
dévoré et qu'elle dit va maintenant je
sais aussi quoi dirhams et animatrice de
khat et à les rendre attentifs sur telle
ou telle question amortiront merci
beaucoup à faire et xavier chavanel je
le rappelle le livre s'intitule je ne
rougis pas de l'évangile et il est
publié aux éditions mame par le diocèse
de versailles merci beaucoup à vous
faire
autre sujet à présent suite aux
attentats de 2015 la politique de
défense française a changé l'armée de
terre doit augmenter ses contingents et
recréer des unités en 2016 ses 15000
postes qui sont à pourvoir en france et
3000 seulement en ile de france les
conditions de recrutement
elle ne change pas il faut être de
nationalité française avoir entre 17 et
32 ans avec ou sans diplôme
ces forains à manier et patrick jacques
de dixmude ont suivi antoine un joli
minois de 20 ans qui effectue et ses
sélections au fort de vincennes la
semaine dernière regarder trois heures
devant un écran à répondre à des tests
psychotechniques de français
mathématiques et anglais
ces tests constituent la première étape
de sélection pour antoine ce jeune
yvelinois de 20 ans en formation de
conducteurs travaux cherchent à intégrer
l'armée de terre en tant que
sous-officier dans le génie travaux
l'une des spécialités proposées par
cette armée on m'avait dit c'était assez
facile en fait est là bas ce matin j'ai
pas trouvé que c'était évident le temps
imparti
ça je ne savais pas ces tests
psychotechniques permettent
deux choses la première qui permettent
finalement d'évaluer sa capacité à
s'adapter au sein des institutions
militaires
donc pour évaluer le potentiel d'un
candidat est également le potentiel
cognitif visant à vérifier sa capacité
ensuite à suivre la formation qui lui
sera dispensée antoine est arrivé hier
après-midi au fort de vincennes après
avoir rempli toutes les formalités
administratives il a passé différents
tests médicaux pour leur direction le
mess pour le déjeuner sous l'oeil
attentif du chef décrire l'horreur pour
leur part manger quand même ne restez
pas à jeun pour les épreuves de sport de
cet après midi ici on entre on parle de
sélection mais c'est un entretien
d'embauché
donc c'est un entretien au rouge qui
furent trois jours il ya tout un tas de
tout un tas de petits de petit détail
qui rentrent en ligne de compte et nous
on est là effectivement pour remarquer
ces détails le bon comportement on va
dire c'est quelqu'un qui est qui
s'adapte après les dernières
recommandations et explications sportive
il est temps pour antoine de s'élancer
dans l'épreuve du luc léger une épreuve
physique pour déterminer la vitesse
maximale aérobie
puis direction le parcours de
coordination
antoine doit réaliser deux fois le
circuit en moins de deux minutes 14 en
franchissant correctement les six
obstacles mais si vous avez effectué par
en 2000 01
vous avez visé pas lavandières semble
être juste qu'il vous fait perdre un
point celle de mano de 19 sur 20 enfin
dernière épreuve sportive les tractions
antoine doit maintenant passer l'épreuve
ultime l'entretien de motivation ils
vont
être reçus en entretien en face à face
par un évaluateur qui va faire le bilan
justement de ces c'est tous les tests
auxquels ils ont été soumis et voir
quelles sont leurs motivations leurs
projets et voir si leur projet justement
est fiable et 6 et 6 sont faits pour
pour ce métier
mais la tâche sera facile pour le
candidat qui rêvent d'intégrer l'armée
depuis l'enfance et plus encore depuis
les attentats de 2015
j'avais déjà eu cette idée en tête de
m'engager après mais là c'est vrai que
le fait d attentats qu'on a suivi ça
pousse un peu les gens à vouloir être
utile à aider leur pays
antoine saura s'il est sélectionné d'ici
une quinzaine de jours
si la réponse est positive le jeune
homme signera son premier contrat comme
204 jeune gibeline eaux en 2015 et
partira dans la foulée faire c'est lui
moi de formation militaire à saint
maixent pour l'armée de terre
quinze mille postes sont à pourvoir en
france en 2016 dont 3000 en ile de
france
et comme à chaque mercredi nous passons
maintenant à la chronique environnement
pour en parler nous retrouvons manip
autebon soir mélanie s'est longtemps
qu'on s'était pas lui pour parler
environnement alors à bois d'arcy
les jardiniers ont déménagé ont aménagé
pardon des lieux de la commune à partir
de matériaux de récupération et vous
allez nous en parler alors cette
démarche elle s'inscrit dans la
politique environnementale de la commune
l'idée est venue des services techniques
de la ville des jardiniers cinq agents
ont réalisé de nouveaux aménagements
écoute et jérémy de masse y est il est
adjoint au maire en charge de
l'environnement il était au micro de
michael et demi d'euros et guillaume le
squer on aurait pu venir pelé
entreprises extérieures pour la création
de massifs c'est directement les agents
qui propose avec des matériaux
réutilisables des plantes aussi
c'est arrivé qu'on avait des programmes
sur des programmes immobiliers ou dans
des rues
donc dans la zac de la croix bonnet e
il y avait trop d'espèces trop de
plantes dans les massifs donc lézarde
jardiniers ont enlevé des plantes pour
les maîtres autres parents en ville et
les agents ont aussi réalisé des
barrières on va les voir sur les images
elles sont construites à partir de
tuteurs d'arbres qui ont été plantés sur
la zone d'aménagement concerté de bois
d'arcy les arbres étant maintenant assez
solides les tuteurs ont pu être enlevé
les pierres aussi ont été récupérés dans
la zac lors des différents travaux
immobiliers alors sur ces aménagements
il ya aussi des copeaux de bois
provenant des arbres élagués de la
commune les copeaux près mais permettent
de créer un paillage une technique de
jardinage évitant notamment la rétention
d'humidité au niveau du sol pendant la
période estivale il est réduit également
l'usagé des produits phytosanitaires
la ville a atteint le zéro phyto alors
petite précision les produits
phytosanitaires ce sont ces produits
chimiques que l'on utilise pour soigner
ou prévenir des maladies de végétaux ou
aussi pour le désherbage
ils appartiennent à la famille des
pesticides zéro phyto c'est donc une
réduction de l'impact sur
l'environnement mais pas seulement
la ville souhaite faire des économies et
l'utilisation de matériaux de
récupération a aussi un impact sur le
prix il n'y a plus ou peu d'achats il ya
moins d'entretien l'aménagement de
l'entrée de ville rue henri barbusse
qu'on voit à l'image a nécessité un
budget de 1700 euros
on peut très vite arriver sur cette
entrée de ville si on passe par une
entreprise extérieure tournait autour
d'eux
10 à 15000 euros les mille les 1700
euros
son
surtout du fait du ciment cartes quand
on achète des pierres pas folle et on a
fait des petits murets en pierres
maçonnées le temps passé par le ministre
y est voilà tout toutes ces petites un
peu de vivaces qu'on a dû racheter parce
qu'on n'a pas pu récupérer toutes les
visées wasa lacroix bonne et voilà
ces éléments là le prochain aménagement
ce sera le square calmette et guérin sur
l'avenue paul vaillant couturier
le cosec lui qui est la zone sportive de
la commune verra bientôt des arbres
fruitiers
merci beaucoup mélanie c'est ainsi que
se conclut ce journal rester avec nous
tout de suite vous retrouver sephora
namani pour un nouveau numéro culturelle
de votre magazine qu'est ce que je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée se revoir